thank I'm here with the lovely Cara
Delevingne right here with the lovely
John Green those are pretty good
imitation yeah you play Margo in the
movie and I'm gonna ask you real
questions by real nerdfighters what's it
like to kiss NAT oh um yeah he's a good
kisser he's a really good kisser I was
actually talking about him with a friend
of mine who's also kissed him and we had
a whole conversation about he was a good
kisser
surprise I wonder what friend that could
be I'm just kidding I know
do you yeah is Margo someone that you
can relate to in a lie shell that's why
I got the part because a lot of the
stories that she went through in the
book and all those cadiz I've been
through before and a lot of the lines
they've actually written in the script
I've said before she runs on the
instinct she just um she does what she
feels in the moment doesn't really think
about the consequences and you're like
that - yeah are you an octopus oh faze
me is John a good executive producer no
ha ha - yes what do I do is executive
producer you are so fun what is Jon like
in real life is he just like in the
videos I would say so
yeah you're but I think you're even
funnier in real life cuz you edit out
all the beautifulness I know a face
touch was coming I knew I wasn't gonna
get out of this video that's some kind
of face touch shaken or Nutella so hot
both what is your opinion of my eyebrows
so they'd be less coarse and they're
actually nice oh good they're a good
texture but they're not as good as yours
what well I mean you have famous
eyebrows literally you maybe have the
most famous eyebrows on earth right now
no whoo yeah you can't even think of
someone it's you have you read the book
Paper Towns yes ofcourse I was really
good I really liked it it was yeah cuz I
didn't actually yeah I didn't know how
good you were
hahaha thanks man I thought you were
gonna be not to be rude but like younger
because you do it from a young person's
perspective so well but I am in fact
really old you are what is your favorite
word my favorite word and my least
favorite word in one is regime how did
you feel when you found out you'd been
cast for this I cried I don't know where
I want it like the whole thing I just
don't know where were you freaking the
freak out
I should buy myself which is a bit sad
but I was hotel room getting ready for
work and I got cold I just started
crying it was too much I knew that you
were gonna get it from when I watched
your audition really yeah it's so nice
what do you want to be when you grow up
president Park mr. an astronaut Oh
laughter not quite mr. fighting Princess
Peach
with a steroid injecting angel gun with
wings on a unicorn multicolored golden
eyes it's true that's detailed someone
is gonna draw that I wouldn't be lying
slash monkey describe your friend nat
wolff in three words rambunctious yep
delicious agree and nutritious strongly
agree yeah yeah totally yeah he's he's
good to be around and funny too none
he's less funny than he is nutritious
yeah hi great would you rather the world
contain a puppy sized elephant or an
elephant sized puppy a puppy sized
elephant yes si si which favorite fruit
passion face what is your favorite color
periwinkle blue and what is the meaning
of life love thanks car thanks for being
in this video so there you have a tank
car devine likes my eyebrows and is an
octopus it occurs to me that I forgot to
say good morning to you in this video so
good morning it's actually nighttime but
good morning now having said that I will
see you on Friday when the project for
awesome begins links in the doobly-doo
to all the project for all of us doesn't
so exciting good bye